well the the
vulnerability comes from a combination
of things
of course the climate
impacts but it has a lot to do with the
level of development of the city the way
it's the country is in terms of its
income
income distribution
how many poor people you have in the
country
uh
it's a com all these factors it's
basically about development overall and
the other main issue is the its
population in the slums
by definition vulnerable in every
respect
vulnerable to economic shocks to climate
shocks
and
now with increased rainfall for example
the slums they are they're not prepared
they're barely prepared for the current
uh rainfall patterns if you make them
more intense and more severe well
the risks increase
mudslides etc is another vulnerability
president bolsonaro who doesn't seem to
have the environment in mind
well that's a major concern and the
president himself is probably the major
threat we have for the environment and
for climate in particular he was elected
with the promises of neglecting and not
paying attention to the environment
first thing he did he wanted to do is to
ban the minister of environment
and then he was he had to
go back on this
but he never gave gave any priority to
the environment whatsoever brazil has
traditionally had a
pretty good
behavior in the negotiations
sometimes more sometimes less but brazil
was more or less the same wavelength as
the
world
community and
bolsonaro was elected
with the explicit objective
of denying climate issues
thinking that environmental concerns
are against development there are
major trade-offs he never understood
that
you know what we're talking about here
is
uh increased growth based on a
sustainable pattern
it's too too complicated for him so how
important could be what they are talking
about in glasgow and do you have any
faith that that could materially change
things
i mean we cannot be
so pessimistic we have to find a way
but certainly we think i personally
think we are not at the next at the
needed speed
so
is perry's uh while paris has been a
major success to the extent that you
know if you look historically put 200
countries together to negotiate
something it takes time but
the planet doesn't care about this
bureaucracy the planet says listen i
have a fever uh two degrees almost
getting to two degrees i don't want to
be at that point you need to speed up so
if cop 26 doesn't come up with
meaningful decisions to change things
what is the outcome do you think
disaster for all of us i mean we we are
in a hurry we need to step back let's
learn let's understand better what this
biodiversity has to offer
the local communities the indigenous
people they know that they've been there
for 5 000 years and they've been dealing
pretty well conserving the forest living
on of its products maybe we could learn
a bit from them